All right.
All right, while people are coming in, this QR code is for
if you would like to type your question. We have microphones.
You are definitely welcome to ask your question in person, but if you would rather
type it in,
you can do that online and it will pop onto the computer here, and we'll read it
out.
Okay.
All right.
All right. With that, we'll get started.
We have a great session today on non-clinical models of cancer.
And I just wanted to introduce the problem that we're trying to
solve, which really is that we have great
high impact studies looking in very mechanistic detail in mice,
sometimes with impressive survival curves.
And so how do we take these findings and translate them into
humans in a way that leads to successful clinical trials?
And so some of the initial questions that come out of this, does my target
pathway even exist in humans? While we can certainly ask, okay,
is my gene of interest there, or my protein?
We have lots of atlas data from many human
tissues. It doesn't necessarily tell you that
that entire pathway and all the proteins that interact with your target gene are
there. So does your drug act similarly in
humans? Certainly an open question.
Are there additional redundancies or regulatory pathways?
Toxicities are incredibly difficult to address.
And then,
is this mouse model that you've used actually relevant to most patients with the
disease, or is it just some subset, and how can we better get at these
questions?
So I think our session today really has sort of three main focuses.
One is improving our mouse models.
Conventionally, we knock out some gene and then implant those knockout
tumors into the flanks of mice. This is very simple to
do, but we're going to hear from three speakers about using,
rather than just whole knockout, point mutations identified from
actual human cancers, and really exquisite
techniques to implant tumors orthotopically in that
relevant organ site. We've got brain, bladder, and
mammary gland all represented. So three outstanding
talks,
looking at familial glioma variants.
Then we'll hear on aging and breast cancer oncogenesis.
Next on fibroblast crosstalk in bladder cancer.
Another issue is that maybe the problems or challenges we face in
humans are more complex than looking in young mice.
And so following on the aging theme, clonal hematopoiesis is
common in humans as we age,
such that the patient population overlapping with many
cancers, often has clonal hematopoiesis.
How does this interface, and how do we model that?
So we're going to hear about nanobioreactors using human
hematopoietic stem cells.
And then we'll close our session really thinking about how we use the human
tumor to model human cancers. And so we hear a lot about
organoids, but we've got three examples of organotypic cultures
where we isolate the human tumor, either by biopsy or
surgical resection. And then it comes with not only the tumor cells, but
also all of the fibroblasts and immune cells that are in there.
And so can we use this for drug screening and analyzing by flow,
by cytokine profiling, or by tumor viability to ask how does
that tumor microenvironment respond to drugs?
So three great talks on this. We'll hear on modeling in
non-small cell lung cancer,
testing antibody drug conjugates in some of these platforms, and then we'll
conclude with cytokine profiling from these ex vivo cultures, and does that
actually predict patient outcome?
So with that, I'm very excited to introduce our first
speaker, who is Tiffany Choi, who's a graduate
student
from Baylor College.
This should come up.
Tiffany? Oh, start. There we go. All
right. Welcome.
All right. So hi everyone. My name is Tiffany.
I'm a graduate student at Baylor College of Medicine, and today I'll discuss
part of my thesis project, which involves
the role of a germline variant in familial glioma.
So as a bit of a background, over 200,000 new cases of
gliomas are diagnosed each year, and the World Health
Organization defines these as either malignant or non-malignant,
malignant tumors accounting for about a quarter of these
cases. And of the malignant gliomas,
glioblastoma, which is the most devastating
and untreatable cancer, makes up about half of them.
So the current standard of care right now is maximal surgical resection, along with
radiation and chemotherapy. However, despite these current treatment regimens,
the survival is still relatively poor.
So as you can see here, compared to
patients with other CNS tumors, glioblastoma patients see a five-year relative
survival rate of merely 7%. Now, this hasn't really changed over the
many decades, so this really highlights the critical need for
efficacious new therapies.
So how do we go about approaching this?
So, most gliomas actually arise from sporadic
mutations,
and WHO has really incorporated this to categorize and
diagnose patients better.
However, we can't really use these as predictive markers since they do occur at
random.
So alternatively, we can look at the 5 to 10% of gliomas that
occur with hereditary predisposition.
So these are familial glioma cases,
and they're roughly defined as having one or more family member that has been
diagnosed with a brain tumor.And although these
familial glioma cases account for only a small portion of all gliomas,
the field has really been able to study these cases and
define a few glioma predisposition genes.
And obviously, the list is really short, but the goal really is
to leverage what we know about these familial glioma cases in
order to
identify and characterize novel germline variants that
could predispose one to developing glioma.
So we started with looking at a gene that we study in the lab, DAM2.
And when we look at the human TCGA
database, we can see that the DAM2 mRNA expression is enriched in
high-grade glioma as well as low-grade glioma.
And not shown here, my lab has also determined that the
overexpression of wild-type DAM2 does promote tumorigenesis in in
vitro and in vivo glioma mouse models.
So with that information, we wanted to know if there exists any
pathological variants of DAM2 in familial glioma
patients. So with the help of Dr. Melissa Bondy at Stanford,
she helped us identify five DAM2 germline variants
in familial glioma patients, and
four of the variants occur in patients with IDH wild-type or
high-grade gliomas, and one patient is afflicted with
oligodendroglioma, which is a type of low-grade glioma.
So with these variants identified, we wanted to then know if they had any
functional role in glioma development.
So in order to do that, I overexpressed each of these variants in a
patient-derived GBM stem-like cell.
And you can see here that the cells that overexpress the R404W
variant actually produces the largest tumor sphere size compared to all
the other groups. And I was curious to see whether this would be recapitulated
in vivo, so I did a classic orthotopic
xenograft with these variant overexpressing cells, and we see
similar results in that the R404W overexpressing
cells have a greater tumor size compared to the DAM2 wild-type
control as well as the GFP control.
You can see this by bioluminescence imaging as well as
cross-sectional histology analysis for gross tumor volume as well
as proliferation by Ki-67 expression.
So in total or together, the in vitro and in vivo data suggest
that the DAM2 R404W variant can promote tumor growth.
However, these experiments were done in models that may not fully
recapitulate what we might see in human patients, as the
overexpression here is limited to just the tumor cells, and these
mice are also immunodeficient, so lacking the immunocompetent
system that human patients have. So to
investigate the role of this variant in a more clinically relevant model, we
decided to create a DAM2 R404W variant
immunocompetent knock-in mouse.
And now that we've generated this mouse, I wanted to ask whether just harboring the
mutation alone could actually elicit any changes in cellular
identity or cellular proliferation.
So I concentrated on the subventricular zone, or SVZ for short.
This is a really highly proliferative area of the brain and the origin of most
brain cells. And so I stained this area with BrdU
proliferation marker as well as cell lineage markers.
And what I noticed was that the R404W mutant
mice had increased number of Sox9-positive, BrdU-positive
cells compared to the wild-type mice.
Now, Sox9 is a marker for glial progenitor cells,
so this suggests that the R404W variant is pushing these cells to a
more glial-like fate.
Interestingly, I did not see any changes in global proliferation,
so I hypothesized that an expansion of glial cells would mean a decrease
in a different type of cell. And sure enough, when I stained for double cortin,
which is a juvenile neuron marker, we can
see a substantial decrease in the double cortin-positive,
BrdU-positive cells in the mutants compared to the wild-type mice.
And so because these mice are a complete whole body knock-in for the
mutation, I was wondering whether or not this change that we see
is a cell intrinsic or extrinsic mechanism.
So to answer that, I decided to isolate neural stem cells from these
wild-type or mutant mice and grow them in culture.
I gave them a pro-astrocytic cue to synchronize their cell fates,
and
that way any kind of differences we see in the two populations would
suggest that maybe it's a cell intrinsic mechanism.
I fixed and stained for the same markers, and we saw
similar results. The mutant showed increased number of
BrdU-positive, Sox9-positive cells as well as a decrease
in the double cortin-positive, BrdU-positive cells.
So together, this kind of highlights that the DAM2 R404W
mutation can confer a more cell intrinsic glial progenitor
state. And now this is really important because it kind of
tips the scales towards a more pro-tumorigenic niche, as it
is widely understood that glial progenitors are often the cell of origin for
glioma. So that leads me to my next question, is what does this
all mean in the glioma context? So as a reminder,
the patient with the 404 mutation has low-grade glioma, and in order
to model that, I decided to use the rCas9-tVA
system, which enables cell type-specific gene delivery to the brain.
So by crossing my 404 mice with Nestin-tVA mice, I'm able
to restrict
viral infection into the Nestin-positive cells, and then by injecting
these chicken fibroblasts that overexpress
PDGF-beta, I should be able to create tumors that
are consistent with low-grade glioma by 100
days.So midway through the progression
of these tumors, I looked at proliferation with OLIG2 as a tumor cell
marker, and you can see a marked increase in proliferating tumor cells in the
form of four mutants compared to the wild-type mice.
And now proliferation is just one aspect of tumor growth.
I wanted to also know whether this mutation
is pushing the progression of these tumors from low
grade to high grade. So by using these WHO tumor
grade two and three as a kind of representative image for comparison,
we can see that the mutant tumors, when
compared to those, have
evidence of hypercellularity as well as nuclear atypia, which are
histological hallmarks of perhaps malignant
transformation. And then my most exciting piece of data,
it's still in the preliminary stages, but it seems that the
survival curve that I have going on shows that the R414W
variant can decrease overall survival in the context
of low-grade glioma.
So, currently I'm working on the mechanism, and I did bulk
RNA sequencing on these tumors. And with
doing gene ontology analysis, looking at all the upregulated
genes here, I found a variety of key biological pathways that are
usually evidenced in being pro-tumorigenic.
So just for example, interferon-mediated signaling as well as
cell cycle regulation. So hopefully in the near future, I'm able to
identify some candidate genes or pathways underlying
this project.
So in conclusion, I hope to have convinced some of you that the
R414W mutation in DAM2 can expand the glial
progenitor pool in vitro and in vivo, as well as
increase the tumor growth across many different glioma
models. And with the
conclusion of my thesis work, I'm hoping to be able to identify
or define and characterize the 414 mutation as a hereditary
variant that drives glioma susceptibility.
So with that, I would like to thank my lab, especially my advisor and
my bench mentor. And a special thanks to my collaborators as
well, Dr. Melissa Bondy at Stanford.
She helped identify these genes and has been very crucial in the
success of this work, as well as Dr.
Rao for providing the reagents available for the low-grade
glioma models.
Thank you all for listening, and I'll be happy to take any questions.
Excellent. Thank you. This is now open for questions.
I guess I'll start with one. So you found this gene sort of out of a
rare familial variant.
Do you think this tells you anything about the unmutated gene?
And so have you looked at transcriptional levels of this
DAM2 in other patients with glioma and
asked, does that correlate with survival?
Yeah. So for glioma patients specifically,
DAM2 mRNA levels at least are increased.
And
in other several cancers as well.
But we haven't really seen how this
R414W variant actually plays into the role of the canonical
role that it has. It has a role in Wnt signaling, and I don't really see any
evidence of promoting Wnt signaling or any kind of
gain-of-function phenotype from this.
Okay.
So
did
you by any chance take advantage of those
case control studies, see whether any variant you study
will cause a cancer susceptibility?
Um-
Or increase the incident rate of occurring?
So the variants that we're looking at are actually not
common variants.
Mm-hmm.
And especially since we're looking at familial glioma cohorts, they're also quite
rare. It could also be just coincidence that it's like a
co-expression of this mutation. It's just along for the ride, like a
passenger mutation. I haven't looked at those, but it would be interesting to
dive deeper.
Great.
All right. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thanks.
All right. Our next speaker is
Thangaraj Warren Mohan,
who will be speaking to us today from UT San Antonio. Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
I'm Thangaraj Deshpriye Mogan from University of Texas at San Antonio.
Today, I'm going to walk you through my study on age-dependent mammary tumor
genesis in mice driven by
the mutant catalytic domain of PI3 kinase protein,
commonly known as PIK3CA.
I have no financial relationship to disclose.
As we know, the breast cancer incidence rises sharply with age.
The estrogen receptor disease predominant in older women at the aged
population are underrepresented in clinical trials.
Most breast cancer research focuses on tumor, but we asked a different
question. What happened even before tumor forms in the
mammary gland, particularly the aged mammary gland?
And specifically asked, does the aged mammary gland harbor epithelial
cells that are intrinsically primed for transformation?
To understand this, we used oncogene-induced murine introductal
model to investigate tumor-adjacent mammary gland and to
evaluate early oncogenic events.
In mouse mammary gland, the ductalThe ductal
lumen are surrounded by the luminal cells inside and the basal cells
are outside, along with the other stromal populations.
This is the preliminary data from our lab.
We separated basal and luminal cells based on the marker CD49f
for basal, CD24 for luminal cells.
These are wild-type FVB mice. We see age-dependent expansion
of basal cells compared to the young mice, and reduction in the
luminal cells. So as we see the striking differences in the
epithelial population, this could be
one of the factor that prime the tissue oncogenic
transformation, along with the stromal remodeling and other epigenetic
reprogramming.
We interested in PIK3CA H1047R, which is a
hotspot mutation frequently seen in the older breast cancer patient,
and also the PI3 kinase/AKT mTOR signaling pathway is
closely associated with the aging biology.
Despite no link between ER positive status, PIK3CA
mutation, the aged mammary epithelial microenvironment
still remain poorly understood.
Which aging epithelial population are most susceptible to PIK3CA
transformation and why it is remain unknown.
So we hypothesized that the mammary gland epithelial microenvironment and their
niche are critical factor that uncovers the tumorigenic potential
of mutant PIK3CA.
To model age-associated PIK3CA oncogenesis, we
use murine introductal model, and we have taken three
age group of mice, ranging from two months to 22 months, which is
typically represent the premenopausal to postmenopausal stage in
human.
We produce a lentivirus which carries PIK3CA
H1047R, and we deliver this oncogene into the mammary
introductal,
using mammary introductal model into the mammary duct.
We produce virus through the lipofectamine-based transfection vector, and the viral
titer was determined prior to the injection.
This slide illustrate the successful injection of
lentivirus into the mice mammary duct.
We add a trace amount of trypan blue to track the
successful injection. So as you can see, the ductal lines
are filled with lentivirus.
After infection, the mice were incubated for
six to seven months. Once they show a palpable tumor, we
terminated the mice.
The C-terminal truncated PIK3CA control has
shown no tumor across the age group.
The whole mount Carmen staining and the hematoxylin and eosin staining looks
normal. In contrast, the oncogene-injected mice shows
benign proliferation and squamous metaplastic carcinoma.
So what happen when we inject mutant PIK3CA on both the
inguinal gland of mice?
This is a tumor incident analysis, not the survival curve, so each
drop represents the day we
monitor the tumor. Surprisingly, the aged mice shows higher
tumor incidence and also early onset compared to the young mice.
This data is from a mice,
but as we injected virus into both the glands,
we considered one gland as a one point.
So this data is similar to the-- It has the same pattern,
similar to this one.
So as you see, the incidence of tumor is higher in
the aged mice compared to the young mice.
So this clearly indicate aging significantly accelerate tumor onset
and increases the tumor incident.
However, the 50% of the mid-aged mice does not develop tumor,
but still it shows micro lesions. This is a
non-palpable gland. When we looked at the
cellular level, it shows highest Ki-67 in both
mid-aged and the aged group. So this indicate the
PIK3CA activate
oncogenic pathway
in the adjacent gland.
Then as we injected PIK3CA oncogene into the mammary
duct, we want to see how the mammary architecture
looks like. So we
did whole mount analysis and the hematoxylin and eosin staining.
As you see, the young mice, they show focal and localized
lesions, but when we move to the mid-aged, to the aged mice,
it shows
epithelial proliferation throughout the duct.
And hematoxylin and eosin staining also confirms epithelial
proliferation.
So as we see the widespread changes in the aging mammary gland,
whether that promote the tumor formation,
we did tumor growth rate analysis.
As you see, the young mice has a higher tumor growth rate compared to the aged
mice, even though the young mice tumor develop, it has a
late onset. But the aged mice has a yearly onset, but
still the tumor growth is slower, which reflects the
human data as we see the
breast cancer older patient shows less aggressive tumor.
Then we did PIK3CA.
We take the estrogen receptor staining across tumor section and the tumor
adjacent gland from all three age group.
Importantly, the tumor adjacent section shows higher
ER positive,
which is expressed only in the luminal cells.
So this indicate the tumor adjacent gland is already hormonally
primed with the expression of PI3 kinase.
Then we want to check whether the
oncogene is expressed
similarly across all the age group.
We did intracellular staining of PIK3CA using FaC-BD FACs cell
sorter.As you see, the protein expression across all the
age groups were comparable. This figure shows
the number of PIK3CA positive cells.
In the young mice, you see the less PIK3CA positive cells, but the mid-age
and aged mice shows higher PIK3CA positive cells, which
indicate the aging microenvironment actively increasing
the PIK3CA clones. And this is
a facts data showing the high PIK3CA positive cells were localized
in the boundary between basal and the luminal layer.
This is the data showing the image of a PIK3CA
high positive cells.
To summarize, we see the young niche is the resistant soil,
and we see only the localized lesions, but the tumor growth
rate is really rapid.
But in the aged mice, we see it's a widespread changes,
but it has a low
tumor growth.
To conclude,
targeting age-associated epithelial changes and the niche, in addition to
the oncogenic pathways may offer new opportunities for cancer
prevention.
The limitation,
this is a murine introductal model which may not fully capture the human
breast cancer biology, and also stromal cells and immune component we
need to analyze.
So to identify tumor-initiating cells in the aged mammary
epithelium
can open the early intervention for the cancer treatment.
Currently, we are doing mRNA sequencing.
We
will also do single-cell RNA sequencing to find out
tumor-initiating cells in the aged mammary gland.
So
the point is we need to have a more focus on the epithelial cells and the stromal
cells.
I
thank AACR for selecting this
presentation and also the award.
I thank other collaborators and my PA, and Jacob
for his support throughout his work.
Thank you.
Go to the middle.
You need to come use the microphone.
Yeah.
Great.
You mentioned looking at ER alpha.
In older mice, do they have the same
menopause that humans go through?
What's the level of circulating estrogen in older mice?
Usually older mice,
it doesn't cycle, but we see some of the mice were cycling.
We see the higher estrogen alpha receptors in the older mice.
How do you build that into your
model next time? Or do you think it's worth building into the model?
It might be...
Sometimes people do ovariectomy.
Sorry?
Don't sometimes
people use ovariectomy, remove the ovaries to remove the circulating
estrogen in older mice?
Do you think that would affect your model?
Removing...
No,
I don't think it can affect our model because the estrogen alpha
receptor is expressed in the tumor, so tumor cells is actually producing the
ER alpha.
The tumor cells make ER? So I think typically estrogen
comes from the ovaries.
No?
Oh, sorry.
Okay, we'll talk after. Thanks.
Yeah.
Yeah, I really like this sort of comparison of young
to aged mice. I wonder if you've thought of extending this to mice who've
had multiple pregnancies.
Sorry?
How do you think that your sort of tumor initiation and growth rates would change
in mice that have had multiple pregnancies?
Have you thought about extending the model to that?
That have given birth to litters, right, and have gone through the
lactation process.
Actually, we worked on the LANIPRO mice, but
I don't have idea how it will be in the pregnancy.
We will look into it.
Okay.
Great.
So you're showing your aged mice, right?
Basically, you see the increase of basal cell, right?
Yeah.
That's what. So I'm wondering whether, in terms of those tumor,
did you
check whether there is difference in the cell origin of cancer between young
and old mice?
Yeah. The aged mice shows lesser luminal cells, but when we inject
PIK3CA, we see more luminal cells compared to the basal
cells. So this PIK3CA actively proliferating the luminal
cells particularly.
Oh, okay. So in the mammary gland, the
luminal cell is the proliferative type cell?
Yes.
Okay.
Did you by chance look at the difference in the tumor,
the
microenvironment between young mice and old mice?
Now you see the MBC niche area, but did you look at the other compartment,
whether there's any difference?
No.
Maybe once we analyze the RNA sequencing data, we will know more information
about this one.
Okay.
So, yeah, I actually have one technical question.
Actually, it is good job for completing those project.
I'm just curious, how successful you can do those
introductal injection, because this is very hard.
Yeah.
For me, initially it was really hard.
Then, we were doing more than five
trials, each including 30, 30 mice.
Then finally,
I am almost 90% successful. But still we have some
unsuccessful mice.
It was really hard, but I get more practice to
do that.
Okay, great.
Thank you so much.
All right, our next speaker is Dr. Philip
Abosh.
He's an assistant professor at Fox Chase Cancer Center, and will be
talking to us about bladder cancer.
Hello, thanks for coming. So Tahmina is the person
that actually drove this project, and she unfortunately is still in
Philadelphia with a childcare issue, so I'm going to stand in for
her. I have a couple disclosures, but nothing
really relevant to the work.
I'll just have a couple of slides on background here.
So bladder cancer,
about 40% of bladder cancers have genetic alterations in the
PIK3 pathway, which we just heard about from the prior speaker.
Thank you for the great introduction.
About
25% or so actually have point mutations
in PIK3 or amplification. Another 5%
have loss of PTEN, and then you also see
deleterious mutations in TSC1 and TSC2, which are negative
regulators of the pathway.
Our first goal for this project was to identify genotype-specific kinase
inhibitor combinations
that might be useful in bladder cancer, because right now there's really not a lot
of targeted therapy in bladder cancer, although clearly there's a lot of
potential for targeted therapy.
We also wanted to develop an immunocompetent bladder cancer
model, a mouse model, to recapitulate these mTOR
mutations and then test nominated kinase
inhibitors in the mouse in an immunocompetent setting.
I'll give a preview of our findings here, and that was that
we got goal one sort of taken care of.
Goal two is where we started to run into some problems, and I'm going to talk a
little bit about that today. Our CRISPR-edited organoids
regress in immunocompetent mice, but
they actually engraft when they're
co-injected with
cancer-associated fibroblasts.
And so this prompted sort of a second arm of this study to investigate
tumor-CAF crosstalk. So this is kind of a
summary of our model.
We started by collecting
EpCAM positive urothelial cells, these are the cells that line the inside of the
bladder, from this special transgenic mouse that was described in
2014 by the Fung Zhong group.
Essentially what you have is a lox stop lox.
So this is a Cre-inducible Cas9 that also expresses
GFP.
This is in all of the cells in its germline.
So you can isolate urothelial cells and then grow them
ex vivo in 3D Matrigel as organoids.
And then we treat them with a Cre induction,
and then we can actually induce point mutations with guide
RNAs in p53, and then we also can induce
loss of the chromosomal segment, a 9p21
homologous segment in mice.
The same
three genes are the same
in mice and in humans.
And then as an additional hit,
we
generated a hotspot point mutation that we actually just heard the last speaker
talk about, this H1047R mutation, which is a
constitutively activated PIK3. Now I will
have a caveat here. So in breast, you actually tend to
see a lot more 1047R mutations, but in bladder, you
actually get E545K. They both constitutively activate
the kinase, but it's a different hotspot, as you can see here
from this lollipop diagram. We tried a
lot of
experiments to try to activate this
E545K mutation. The problem we ran
into is there's not really a good PAM site for our CRISPR enzyme
that's close to E545K, but we're actually really
easily able to make the 1047 mutation.
We used a molecular trick that's described by Kan et al. in 2017.
So once we
generated these hotspot mutations, we
isolated single-cell clones and then treated them with
clinically approved PIK3
kinase inhibitors. And you see here this red line is the
PIK3 wild type
organoid line, and then these other dotted lines
have the 1047 mutation. These are all individual single-cell clones that we
expanded. So you see that there's a sensitization to
both piptilicide and also to alpelisib.
So this is really exciting because these are two potentially personalized medicine
strategies we could use in bladder cancer that
these don't exist today. So this is sort of the rationale for a
personalized medicine approach.
And then in addition, if you compare the platinum sensitivity,
so at the time we did these experiments, cisplatinum was the
sort of de facto standard of care.
Both genotypes have about the same sensitivity to platinum.
But you see that again, the
alpelisib, the specific kinase inhibitor,
the cells are
sensitized to the drug.
So then we wanted to start putting these...
And
I'm not showing it, but we did some additional western blot
of phosphoprotein.
Western blots have showed that you can essentially inhibit most of the pathway with
these inhibitors.So then we went to engraft
these
cells in mice. We actually first tried to put them
orthotopically. They don't grow orthotopically.
And then we started putting them in flank
engraftment and they start, and then they sort of start to
regress. So these are all luciferase-labeled
cells, and when we put them in, as you can see, by week four, they sort
of regress. Now, if you implant them in an immunocompromised
mouse, they grow very robustly. There's a
palpable lesion, and you can resect it and do
histology, and it looks like a tumor.
Well, we sort of
shot this idea around to several of our colleagues at my institution.
We have a really strong tumor microenvironment group who suggested
maybe we should
implant them with CAFs. So the way we did this was actually to isolate our own CAF
line using mice that were exposed
to BBN, which is a carcinogen. These mice get
tumors over the course of about four to six months.
We then isolated the tumor and then grew out CAF lines and then started
putting those in with the organoids.
And lo and behold, they actually formed tumors, again,
in the flank, but not orthotopically.
So then
that sort of gave us the
model to start treating them with the kinase inhibitor
in vivo. And what you can see here is that with the
alpelisib,
the tumors do shrink. But
interestingly, they shrink in both the
hotspot
organoid line as well as the
baseline organoid that doesn't have the hotspot.
So it
seems like both genotypes in vivo are
sensitive, and so maybe it's something related
to the tumor microenvironment.
We did show that
there was also a decrease in Ki67
expression, so cell proliferation
that was statistically significant.
So in this model, we see a
sarcomatoid feature that tends to be decreased with the treatment of
the kinase
inhibitor, as well as
increased E-cadherin staining, suggesting that we're reversing
an EMT phenotype.
So in summary, the PIK3 hotspot does
sensitize our organoids to clinically relevant
kinase inhibitors.
And maybe in vivo, there's some
growth
suppression. And then
although it's not quite as genotype specific as we had expected it to
be,
we do see some histological changes that are consistent with the drug's
activity. And now we're doing a little bit more in terms of these
immunocompetent mouse models to test alpelisib versus platinum,
the sort of standard therapy. So
we started to then
characterize the CAF-organoid crosstalk.
And the way we did this was to just co-culture the two cell types and
then use a multiplex ELISA assay. And what we see is
that when you co-culture the CAFs and the organoids, you
see GM-CSF and interleukin-6. There's literature that
suggests that these
cytokines induce a immunosuppressive organoid
environment. But when we did these experiments, we didn't know whether the IL-6
or the GM-CSF was coming from the organoid or from the CAF.
So we took conditioned media from each cell type and
crossed it and found that the IL-6 was coming from the
CAFs, and the GM-CSF was coming from the organoids.
So then we did a GM-CSF knockout with the
Cas9 enzyme that was already in these cell lines and showed
that when we knock out GM-CSF, IL-6 is now
not
expressed with these conditioned media experiments.
But unfortunately, when we did a sort of small pilot experiment,
the GM-CSF knockout did not reliably
shrink tumor formation. So in summary,
for this CAF portion of the talk, we do think that CAFs are necessary for tumor
engraftment in immunocompetent mice.
And we think that there's a GM-CSF IL-6
crosstalk, but the significance is still to be determined.
We have several future experiments lined up, and I'll just make some
acknowledgments because I'm about a minute over time. So thank you.
Great. Excellent.
I'll start with some questions. I think this would be
great if you could ask about the tumor CAF crosstalk in tumors that are
just growing with their endogenous CAFs.
So in thinking about what's causing this immune-mediated
rejection in the immunocompetent mice,
two potential sources. Luciferase is a very strong antigen.
Yeah.
Do you need luciferase? And then, was the strain background from the
original mouse you came from, was it fully B6 or
sort of-
Yeah. Good question. So,
I'll pull the curtain back a little bit.
We've been working on this project, I'm ashamed to say, for 10 years.
And these are all questions we've been thinking about.
So we got the in vitro part of this done very quickly, and then
the in vivo tumor engraftment thing has been a real pain in the
butt. So yes, we have knocked out lucifer-- or sorry,
not knocked out, but done organoids that don't have
luciferase.
So
the mice that we're putting them back into are the same.
They're also the Lox stop Lox mouse, the plat mouse.
So
they should be isogenic.
Okay.
The organoids, these organoids are actually derived from a female.
We thought that maybe it was like a female-male thing or a male-female.
It doesn't matter where they go.
They just don't seem to grow. I mentioned
our colleague at Fox Chase who's a CAF biologist, actually gave
us a different mouse
CAF line that for some reason actually seems to help them grow even better than
the bladder tumor CAFs that we started with.
Sorry, and you had another, or did I address both? You said the luciferase.
Oh, and the genotype. Yeah. So they're the same genotype.
Great. Thanks.
Oh.
Wonderful talk. I was just curious about, you said that IL6 is coming
from the CAFs, right?
The IL6, yeah.
So did you see any type of like a JAK-STAT signature in your tumors?
And did you think that the cross-talk between JAK-STAT and your
PIK3CA mutant could be enhancing the survival in the
flank?
Yeah, good question. We have the tumors.
We could stain for like a phospho-STAT, STAT3
or ja-- Yeah. We haven't done
it. It's a good idea. It's probably something we should do.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Great talk, as usual. So my question is,
do you think that the CAFs are
reversing the
immunosuppression, or do you think that they are directly stimulating the
proliferation of the cancer cells?
Good question. So we haven't looked at whether they directly stimulate the
CAFs-- Sorry, the organoids to...
And that would actually be a pretty easy experiment to do with our conditioned
media model. Our hypothesis on the
cytokines that we picked up that get induced when they're co-cultured,
there's several
publications that suggest that those two cytokines convert,
I think it's monocytes to M2 macrophages, like a
MDSC phenotype. I didn't show it, but we've done some
staining. There's not a great M2 marker, but I think a CD206,
if I recall, is the marker that we looked at.
That does seem to be increased in the tumors when they engraft,
compared to tumors as they're regressing, like if we don't put the CAFs in
the organoid or in the engraftment.
So we think it's more immunosuppression than a proliferative effect.
And they grow in NSG, is that correct?
Is that-
They grow robustly in NSG, right.
So have you tried other sort of less immunosuppressed strains?
Yeah. We've also tried SCID mice, which I think are less
considerably. And they do grow in SCID as well.
And we can actually get them to grow orthotopically in these
immunocompromised mice as well.
Thanks.
Yeah, thanks.
So,
for your in vitro model, so I saw you implant the tumor
like subcutaneously, right?
In vivo, yeah. Mm-hmm.
So is it possible like implant orthotopically into the
bladder or?
Yeah. We've tried a bunch of different approaches.
So you can put them transurethrally.
You catheterize the mouse with a little tiny, like an IV that you would put in a
kid who's in the hospital. You can get that into the urethra and then
squirt cells in there. But before you squirt the cells in, you have to disrupt
the
urothelium, or they won't stick. So we've tried multiple
vesicants to get them to stick. We can actually get them to
stick and engraft, and you can look at the
bladder a week later and it'll be GFP positive, like the entire lumen will
be GFP positive. But if you come back three weeks later, it's back to normal.
So,
we've also tried to inject
percutaneously.
And then we've also tried to come in tangentially to the bladder
to
basically make a bubble in the wall of the bladder, and neither of those approaches
will help them engraft either.
Okay.
Yeah. Thanks.
Great talk.
Yep.
Great. Thank you.
All right. Our next speaker is Dr. Anna Pasto from
GlaxoSmithKline, who will be talking to us
about organoids in lung cancer. Thank you.
Good afternoon, and thank you so much.
I want to just start thanking the organizer for selecting this
talk. And this is my disclosure.
I'm not going to spend much time to remind you that non-small
cell lung cancer, with its rapid growth and early metastatic
onset, represent one of the first common cause
cancer-related death-wise, both for male and female.
The immunotherapy has completely transformed non-small cell lung cancer treatment.
However, only a small percentage of patients actually respond.
So then it's pretty clear that there is a need to predict the
immunotherapy susceptibility and
to stratify the patient in order to identify which one
will respond, and at the same time trying to identify
targeted therapy. We have decided to do this,
exploring patient-derived organoids as a novel
preclinical in vitro system. Patient-derived organoids are these
3D cellular structure that originated from a
small piece of tissue, of cancer tissue.
And to date, patient-derived organoids has been established
from the majority of tumor tissue, brain, lung, breast,
liver, of course, with different successful rate.
But the beauty of this system is that the patient-derived organoids
can actually maintain the genetical functional and
architectural characteristics of the original tumor type.
At the same time, the patient-derived organoids can actually be
established in a donor match, like healthy tumor or
primary metastatic site.
They can also be established fromthe genotype of
interest like MSI and MSS, but also
they can be established using longitudinal sampling, meaning
collecting the tumor tissue at different time during
pre, post, and during the treatment.
In GSK, we have established this integrated multiomic
platform based on the use of patient-derived organoids, the digital
biological twin. Basically, we collect tumor
tissue as well as blood sample from nose mos cell lung cancer patient.
From the tumor tissue, a small piece is then used to perform
spatial transcriptomic analysis as well as multiplex
immunofluorescence analysis. Whereas from the other part of the tumor tissue, we
can establish the organoids. The organoids are then expanded
and exposed to different drug
according to the different axis, and then co-culture with immune
cells. And at the same time, we run multiple assay,
including cytotoxicity, transcriptomic analysis, but also full
proteomic analysis on the extracellular vesicle collected
from the media from which the organoids are growing,
and then multiplex imaging and immunophenotyping like through
flow cytometry. All the data collected from all these
different analysis will be then integrated together with
additional analysis performed on the exosome isolated from
the blood samples. And then through the support of the AI ML
team, we are trying to stratify patient, but also trying
to identify potential biomarker and mechanism of
resistance. And today, I'm going to present you some preliminary
data that we have obtained using this platform.
From tumor tissue collected from 11
patient with nose mos cell lung cancer independently of the
histology, meaning either adenocarcinoma or squamous
cell lung cancer, we have generated patient-derived organoids.
And the first analysis that we perform has been the
comparison between the spatial transcriptomic
performed on the tumor tissue and the
bulk RNA-seq performed on the organoid.
The spatial transcriptomic analysis has been performed
in a restricted manner according to the tumor domain.
And if you want to know a little bit more about how we did
actually perform the single cell segmentation and the
different domain identification, I will suggest
you to go to visit our poster that we're going to have in the next
following days.
The comparison analysis between the spatial transcriptomics and the
RNA-seq reveal how the patient-derived organoids
model can fully recapitulate the transcriptomic differences between
the squamous and the adenocarcinoma phenotype.
As you can see here,
they both share pathways including
proliferation
pathways, but also hypoxia response pathway, as well as
interferon gamma and alpha response.
At this point, because we also collected all the information about this
patient, and we have all the clinical information
regarding the follow-up period that
has been now for more than two years, we've been able
to categorize the patient into not responder or
responder accordingly to events like relapse or death
or no events at all. As you can see here from the
summary data, this dichotomy, not responder,
responder, do not significantly correlate with any clinical
associated info, including PD-L1 status or the
mutation. But when we decided to
translate this dichotomy into the patient-derived organoids,
we have observed that the patient-derived organoids established from the patient
classified as responder, meaning no event at all within two
years,
were actually presenting an enrichment in the activation of the
inflammatory associated pathway, as you can see here from this
cartoon. So to better understand what was going on in
this patient-derived organoids, we decided to co-culture
all these 11 samples with pre-activated immune
cells, all generated from the same healthy
donor in order to reduce the additional variability.
And then we keep untreated or we expose to cisplatin.
And what we observed that was not actually
expected is that
the penetration of CD45 positive cells
was much higher in the patient-derived organoids classified as
not responder accordingly to the patient.
And this was not linked in any manner to the different
histology of the nose mos cell lung cancer samples.
So when we
analyze it even in deeper manner, the profile
of these infiltrated immune cells, we actually find
out that the CD8 infiltrated the not
responder patient-derived organoids were actually characterized
by a predominantly exhaustion profile.
And this was evident in the untreated organoid as well
as in the organoid exposed to cisplatin.
So patient-derived organoids
represent a potent tool
that is able to recapitulate all the tissue signaling,
but also can predict in some manner the
patient response. It can be used to expose
to drug or drug combination and can help to stratify patient, but also
to collect as many information as possible to
predict the response of the patient, but also to stratify
them and identify potential
biomarker.And with this, I wanted to thank all the
people in GSK that's been working on this project, as well as our
collaborator at King's College of London,
and of course, the people at Guy's and St. Thomas Hospital.
But most importantly, I want to thank you, all the patient, whose contribution
is fundamental to do this research. And thank you for your attention.
All right.
Excellent.
I'll start with a question. So
you're reconstituting organoids that have been treated with
cisplatin with CD8 T cells and asking about infiltration
into the tissue. It looked like that correlated a little
bit with the response to cisplatin
sort of initially. Can you speak a little bit about cisplatin
sensitivity and the resulting T cell phenotypes that you got?
Yeah. There is,
of course, a different sensitivity to cisplatin, and this seems to correlate a
little bit, but it's not significantly correlating with the actual
response of the patient to the real treatment.
So, of course, the presence of the immune compartment is quite
important in giving the direction of the response.
So I think it's important to consider the totality of
the different subset. And of course, going back to the
talk that we just listened, the presence of CAF can also
mediate this response. So,
the response to the drug elaborated by cytotoxicity
restricted to the tumor cells is not enough to predict the
real patient response. We need to consider multiple aspect.
Great.
Hey, a wonderful talk. So you showed a slide where you showed how the
patient-derived organoids and culture correlate with the spatial
graphing data, right? And you showed that there was overlap between there.
But what I think is really interesting is where they don't overlap.
I saw in the spatial transcriptomic geo profile, I saw notch
signaling there that you didn't see in the patient-derived organoids.
Do you think that has something to do with the responders and the
inflammation
observation?
Yeah, that's a good question. It might be.
Of course, the pathway that you see there are not overlapping, most
likely are the most important, and most likely are the one that might be affected
by the other component that we are actually missing in this
system.
Yeah. Great talk. Thank you.
Thank you.
Hi. Nice talk.
I was just wondering about your establishment rates with these
organoids and how many you have to try to get positive
results, and if there are differences between molecular subsets.
Are you referring to the successful rate for the organoid establishment?
So it depends on the tumor type. As you might know, there are
some tissue from which the organoid establishment, the
successful rate is really high, like the colorectal.
Other, like lung, it might be more difficult.
And I would say that the secret is the
composition of the media that you're using, because that makes a huge
difference. And there are still some tissue for
which the successful rate is super, super low, but we're
getting there.
Okay. Thank you.
Excellent. Thank you again.
Thank you.
Thanks.
So our next speaker is Emma Clarkin from UCSD.
Hello, everyone. My name is Emma, and I'm an SRA here in Dr.
Katrina Jamieson's lab at University of California, San Diego.
And today, I'm going to be discussing using a 3D biosensing
nanobioreactor to visualize RNA splicing dynamics
in APOBEC3 overexpressed aged bone marrow.
To begin, RNA splicing is a critical regulatory process
that controls isoform diversity and is essential for stem cell
function. Even subtle isoform changes can alter stem
cell fate, and splicing dysregulation is highly associated with
hematopoietic disease and implicated in aging.
However, how aging impacts RNA splicing is yet to be fully
understood. APOBEC3 enzymes could provide a potential
link.
These cytokine-inducible mediated elements enzymes
mediate RNA
editing and can influence splicing by editing splicing
regulatory elements. Our lab has previously shown
that in
inflammatory stress environments,
APOBEC3C is
increased in
hematopoietic stem cell populations.
Additionally,
it is widespread RNA dysregulation.
Therefore, we aim to study how RNA splicing is
deregulated in aging and how splicing deregulation acts in
response to APOBEC3 base deaminase microenvironments.
APOBEC3 is a base deaminase that was originally recognized as
a base deaminator that can
restrict retroviral integration.
However, deregulation of APOBEC3 mediated C to T
editing has emerged as a major source of mutagenesis in a broad
array of diseases. However, in the context of aging,
APOBEC3C is overexpressed in inflammation within
the bone marrow microenvironment called inflammaging.
This inflammatory state could drive activation of APOBEC3
enzymes.And in our study, we plan to focus on
HSPCs. During aging, HSPCs undergo progressive
decline in regenerative capacity, exhibit skewed differentiation towards
the myeloid bias, as well
as an increase in susceptibility to hematological diseases.
Importantly, splicing dysregulation has recently become a
recognized important player in pre-cancer progression,
as well as APOBEC3C.
To further explain why we are interested in studying APOBEC3C as well
as splicing in aging, I would like to highlight two papers
published by our lab. Previously, we have seen
age-associated splice isoform expression in HSCs and
HSPCs or HPCs.
As you can see in the aged HSCs, there is a clear distinct
difference in splice isoform signatures compared to those of the young
HSCs. Additionally, in HPCs, you can see
a similar phenomenon, although there is slightly more
variability.
Additionally, on the other hand, in MPNs that arise from an
inflammatory bone marrow environment, we observed APOBEC3C
overexpression or higher expression, specifically in high-risk
myelofibrosis,
as well as an increase in C to T mutations.
Which in summary, we have evidence of splicing changes in aging, as well
as increased splicing activity in inflammatory disease.
Therefore, we hypothesize that in aging context,
APOBEC3C could be seen as a initiator of
pre-cancer.
While these studies were going on, our lab manager, Jessica Pham, was
also developing these 3D biosensing nanobioreactor
systems. They're originally used to study aging in low
Earth orbit, but if you're interested in learning more about the space experiments
we do with these bioreactors, you can feel free to visit Jessica Pham's
poster on Wednesday. However, in this
context, APOBEC3C is primate specific, which makes it
really difficult to study in in vivo models.
This bioreactor system recreates a human bone marrow
microenvironment and allows us to analyze in real time the effects of
APOBEC3C driven alternative splicing in
HSPCs.
Therefore, for phase one of our
experimental design,
we first receive bone marrow samples through a collaboration
at Scripps Green with Dr. Anna Katatrian, and those samples are then
selected for the peripheral blood mononuclear cells.
These are then selected for the CD34 positive
fraction through gravitational selection processes, and the negative
fraction is seeded directly into these nanobioreactor systems.
Inside this bioreactor, there is a SurgiFoam sponge, which is what recreates that
bioreactor or that human
environmental niche.
Then the 34 positive fraction is transduced with our
MAP2 splicing reporter. The way the splicing reporter works is when exons
are being skipped, it expresses GFP fluorescence, and when exons are being
included, it shows RFP expression.
After 72 hours, these cells are then reintegrated into this bioreactor
system,
where we can then visually image them.
Here you can see a Z-stack model of what is inside
one of these nanobioreactor systems.
There is red and green fluorescence for both of the types of cells that are either
exhibiting exon skipping or exon inclusion events in that SurgiFoam
sponge while surrounded by their fellow
stromal CD34 negative fractions that are non-transduced.
Another way of visualizing this that we're able to do is to do
a time lapse video of these cells in the bioreactor system.
As you can see, over time, these cells start to migrate
towards that SurgiFoam sponge that recreates the bone marrow niche.
I'm not sure if I can circle them, like this one that's moving along surrounded
by other types of cells.
This led us to wonder how APOBEC3C could influence this
bioreactor system.
Whole transcriptome sequencing that was previously done showed an
increase in exon-skipping events in aged bone marrow that has
APOBEC3C overexpression. Additionally, you can see almost a
tenfold increase in aged bone marrow that's overexpressed with APOBEC3C
compared to that of cord blood that is overexpressed with
APOBEC3C. The key here is that in aging context, there
appears to be an increase in APOBEC driven splicing
changes. Additionally, we see an increase in expression of
genes that are necessary for splice site recognition and spliceosome assembly,
such as SRSSFs and SF3Bs.
If you'd like more information on this, I also recommend visiting Inga Vanderwerf's
poster. That'll be tomorrow morning.
And this leads us to phase two of our experimental design, which is exactly the
same up until the first transduction.
12 hours after that first transduction is complete, we then
undergo a second transduction with either an overexpression of
APOBEC3C or an empty PCH backbone
before moving them back into the bioreactor systems.
Here you can see three different aged bone marrow samples that have undergone this
transduction. The first top row showing the PCH empty
backbone transduced cells, while the bottom row shows an
APOBEC3C overexpressed samples.
As you can see, there's a shift from red to green between the PCH to
A3C samples. And to further validate
this,
we did a FACS analysis that shows a
increase in GFP expression in the APOBEC3C transduced
aged bone marrow cells, as well as a decrease in the shift
of RFP to GFP expression throughout these
cells.And this provides strong functional evidence that
APOBEC3C promotes an exon skipping in aged
human HSPCs. And once again, more information from this can be found
on Inga Vanderwerf's poster tomorrow morning.
And then finally, altogether, this work establishes a scalable,
non-clinical 3D platform to functionally model RNA splicing
dysregulation and its role in cancer evolution in an
age-relevant context. Additionally, we found that APOBEC3C
can change RNA splicing, and ongoing studies will leverage this
platform to compare young and aged bone marrow to define RNA
splicing-based biomarkers predictive of hematopoietic aging and
malignant evolution.
And then with that, I would like to thank everyone in my lab, specifically Dr.
Jamieson and Dr. Vanderwerf, for all of their help throughout this.
It takes a whole village, and I appreciate all of them.
So with that, I'm happy to take any questions.
Great talk.
Any question from audience?
So
Yvelanda, so
I'm curious, do you know whether APEX3
can directly work on RNA, or you think APEX3 affect the
splicing because the inference are the splicing factor?
Mm-hmm. So an indirect versus direct conflict.
Of course, we don't fully know, and so that's what the research is focusing on.
But we do think that because it would be influencing
the splicing by affecting splicing to splicing regulatory elements such
as the splicing donor site or splicing acceptor site, which would prevent
that spliceosome from occurring or from attaching,
binding.
Great, thanks.
Great talk.
So what is the constitutive
localization of APOBEC3C in the cell?
Is it cytoplasmic, nuclear?
And is that consistent with the expected
mechanism for altering the splice sites?
Yeah. So that would be cytoplasmic.
However, I'm not sure how it would directly affect that splicing site
from that.
So could you think maybe of an experiment where you
change the localization of A3C
from, for example, cytoplasmic to nuclear, and see that
the effect goes away?
And do you think this
is mediated through directly RNA editing or?
Yes. We do think that it happens directly through RNA editing.
However, looking at that changing in cytoplasmic, that would be
something we'd have to look further into.
Thank you.
So is your laboratory has plan to commercialize this
very cool nanoreactor?
That would definitely be fun to commercialize it.
For now, it's just research in the lab, but it is patented for anyone that-
Very cool
... wants to follow in our footsteps.
Great. Thanks.
Thank you.
So our next speaker is Dr. Felix Berg from
vitrosken.
Thank you. Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Felix. I'm a senior scientist at vitrosken.
We are a startup based in the Netherlands.
And I would like to start with thanking the organizers for
selecting our talk here, giving us the opportunity to share
some of our data on ex vivo tumor testing and how that
can inform clinical development of antibody-drug
conjugates.
These are my disclosures.
To start off,
I think as you're all very well aware, antibody-drug conjugates are by
now an established treatment modality in cancer care.
And the central promise behind those is that you can combine the
specificity of monoclonal antibodies with the
potency of the cytotoxic payloads these are conjugated
with.
And this has translated into quite some clinical successes,
given that by today more than 15 ADCs are
approved and
regularly used in the clinic, and many more ADCs are
currently in preclinical development.
However, there are also many challenges regarding the development
of ADCs, and this is not least due to the fact that
a lot of preclinical models that are used
to assess ADCs before going into the clinic are
often poorly translational. So you see a lot of ADCs
entering preclinical trials but then basically failing, and this
is most often due to the lack of efficacy.
So we and others believe there's a high need to
improve
models so that you have a higher predictive value of what the
patient responses to these anti-drug conjugates will be later
on in the clinic.
And for this, we apply what we call ex vivo
microtumors. So these are basically tumor samples derived from
patients, minimally processed, that
recapitulate
the situation that you have in basically the tumor in the patient
most closely, in particular, if you compare this to other
preclinical models such as PDX models, organoids, or cell lines,
particularly in the context of heterogeneity within the
tumor, and I'll show some data on that, but also heterogeneity
between patientsAnd last but not least,
the presence of the native tumor and
microenvironment, which can be preserved
using these approaches.
So our platform
basically looks like this in very simple terms.
We get patient samples. We primarily focus on solid cancers.
Most of our experience is with ovarian cancer, and I'll share quite some data on
that today.
But also we have data on non-small cell lung cancer,
bladder cancer, and colorectal cancer.
We process these samples
minimally in a mechanic fashion, and then those are seeded in
384-well plates, exposed to
relevant drugs or combinations thereof.
And then after a certain incubation period, the tissue
is then fixed and stained, imaged in 3D,
and then we use basically high-content imaging
analysis to extract morphological features and define
efficacy profiles for the drugs that were being tested.
We can then also correlate this with data we collect from the
clinic,
where you can then basically align treatment efficacy
with clinical parameters.
And on top of the assay, we can build complementary
assays to further characterize the treatment
response. That can be looking into immune cells, profiling, target
antigen expression, as well as more general omic
approaches,
and cytokine profiling.
So to look at the predictive value of our platform,
we've run a retrospective trial where
we looked in primary ovarian cancer,
and then took these ex vivo micro tumors we
established from
a cohort of ovarian cancer patients and tested the
responses of chemotherapy, targeted therapy, and immunotherapies on
these samples, and at the same time, followed up the
response of these patients then to standard of care
chemotherapy, which in a context of ovarian cancer is a combination of
carboplatin and paclitaxel.
And then if we compare the response we see in the,
there we go, ex vivo platform,
with the eventual clinical response of the patients, and in this case, we
use C125, an established biomarker for clinical
responses in ovarian cancer. We see a very nice correlation between the
ex vivo response and the clinical response.
And more importantly, if we
basically stratify the patient population
based on the ex vivo response that we see in these
samples, you can appreciate that there's a
significantly longer progression-free survival in the
patients with a predictive high
response compared to the ones that show a low response in the ex vivo
platform. So really highlighting the predictive value of that, at
least in the context of chemotherapy.
Moving to antibody-drug conjugates, we then did a
case study where we tested, again in ovarian cancer,
an antibody-drug conjugate, in this case, mirvetuximab
sorafenacin,
which is a folate receptor alpha-targeting ADC
that is conjugated to a microtubule inhibitor.
And we tested this in ex vivo tumor samples from
25 ovarian cancer patients. And what we
saw is that we have a wide range of response profiles in
terms of how efficient the ADC is in killing these
micro tumors, ranging from relatively resistant patients,
such as patient one here highlighted in blue, to relatively sensitive
patients, patient two highlighted in green.
And on the right, you can also appreciate the
microscopy pictures from the micro tumors we have here.
In the platform, we can also test, as I mentioned before,
multiple therapies,
both separately and in combinations.
And in this case, what we did is also take a long standard of care
chemotherapy and compare then the responses to these
carboplatin, paclitaxel, and topotecan to the response
of MIRF. And what we can see here is a very nice
correlation of the ADC MIRF, so
the response to the ADC MIRF to paclitaxel, while this is
less the case for carboplatin and topotecan.
And to us, that made sense, given that
both the payload of MIRF as well as paclitaxel, they target microtubules.
So there's a very similar mode of action,
showing basically the
complementary fashion where you can evaluate different treatments
within this platform.
Importantly,
we can also test combination
treatments in the platform. So what we did here, this is again an
ovarian cancer, but a different antibody-drug conjugate, seeing if
there's any synergistic effects when combined with a PARP
inhibitor, olaparib.
And what we saw is that for some patients, similar to, for
example, here, this control
condition, we see some responses to the
ADC highlighted here on the horizontal line in a dose-dependent manner,
as well as to the PARP inhibitor, olaparib.
But if you look at the diagonal, basically that representing the combination
treatment, you really see a nice synergistic effect, while this is
observed in some patients, but not in others, for example, in this
patient, where most of the response is really driven by olaparib.
So no synergism observed
here.And then lastly, and I think
that's also quite relevant in the ADC field, is we
can profile ADC
target antigen expression in these microtummors,
both prior and after treatment.
So just as an example here, we profiled a
cohort of patients for a specific ADC target, and we
observed quite some
intra-patient heterogeneity in this, as well as inter-patient
heterogeneity in a sense that, for example, for patient one,
we see a rather broad expression of the ADC target
antigen at a moderate expression level,
while in patient two, only some of the microtummors do express
the target antigen, but then at relatively high levels.
And we can then also look at this post-treatment to, for
example, evaluate specificity of the treatment as well as bystander
effects.
So to summarize,
the ex vivo microtumor testing platform we
established can predict clinical responses to chemotherapy in the
ovarian cancer context. And
translating this to the antibody-drug conjugate
treatment modality, we can observe patient-specific
ex vivo ADC responses.
We can evaluate combination treatments of the ADC with
other established therapies, profile target antigens, and
correlate those with sensitivity profiles.
And then lastly, obviously, this antigen profiling is not
just restricted to ADC target antigen, but can be to
any biomarker available, so that can also then be used to
stratify patients based on their response.
And beyond ADCs, we're now also setting up the platform
to evaluate targeted therapies, so you can think of small molecule
inhibitors, but also immunotherapies.
And on that, we'll have a poster tomorrow, so I'll invite you
if you're interested in that, would like to invite you to visit us there.
With that, I would like to thank the whole team at Vitrosken, as well
as our clinical collaborators in the Netherlands and other parts of
Europe,
and also first and foremost, patients and their families.
Without basically the tissue donation, this work would not be
possible. And I would like to thank you for your attention and happy to
take any questions.
Hi,
Felix. Thank you for your nice talk.
I have a technical question about how you culture the microtummors.
Do you embed them in any hydrogel matrix, like Matrigel or collagen, or
are they just suspended in the media?
Good question. They are embedded in a hydrogel.
It's not Matrigel, it's sort of a proprietary mix.
And we also see,
as we already had earlier the discussion and I think also throughout the
conference,
we see it's really indication dependent, sort
of what the optimal culture conditions is, particularly with
regard to CAF content in these samples.
So yeah.
I have a second question.
Yes.
What do you think is the biggest advantage of your microtumor platform
compared to a standard PDO, like patient-derived organoids?
Because to me, they look kind of similar.
That's a fair question.
So we believe given that there's really no
culture or passaging done with these samples, that it most
closely resembles the complexity you have in really the
patient tumor tissue. We've done profiling in terms of
basically
putting the
patient sample
unprocessed and then processed in the lab next to each other, and we see very
good preservation of different components of the TME,
especially also myeloid components that often
do not
cope well with multiple passaging in, for example, the context of
PDX models.
So the ex vivo
system can be passaged or
generally, you don't passage them?
We don't passage it. So the whole
assay really from sample collection to
having the results is about 10 days,
and by that, we end the assay, yeah.
So
did the company try whether this ex vivo system can
also predict other treatment modality?
Yes, that's the goal. So what we're
now working on is, in collaboration with
one of the hospitals that are on here,
also link that to other treatment modalities.
So we run along in clinical trials where we collect
the patient samples through our ex vivo testing on drugs
that the patients also receive. So again, sort of a retrospective
trial in this case to see if the responses we
observe in the ex vivo platform then also can be predictive
to responses that are seen in the clinic.
Great.
Very nice talk. Do you see any difference in the success
of the culture between primary and recurrent ovarian cancer?
Less so in that regard. We do see quite some difference in
terms of treatment history. So we've noticed
if
prior chemotherapy was less than four months
ago, then we see a significant drop in the success of the culture,
but it's less regarding to sort of disease state.
Great.
Is there any more question?
Okay, great. If we don't have, then I will move to the
last speaker of today.
Thank
you.
So
our last speaker is Dr. Erika Van Aeou
from
Elephas BioScience. Yeah.
Good afternoon, everyone. I would like to thank the AACR
organizers to invited us to present our work.
Today, I would like to discuss how at Elephas, we have
defined immune phenotype of immune checkpoint inhibitor responses
using live tumor fresh samples and
preserving the tumor microenvironment. This is my disclosure slide.
I think at this point, and after two days of being around AACR, everyone
knows how immune checkpoint inhibitor have changed the
landscape of the solid tumor cancer treatment
patients.
We also are aware that if we take 100 patient,
only half of them are eligible through the
FDA-approved biomarkers. And from those that they are
eligible, only 20% of them, one in five,
respond. So here is where Elephas
is coming to measure the immune response to immune
checkpoint inhibitors in a live tumor fragment
while we are preserving that tumor microenvironment.
Let me tell you how we do this.
Elephas has developed eLive. eLive is a
platform where we take,
in the clinical setting, core needle biopsy,
or in the translational setting, when we are working with pharma and
collaborators, resections. After we take the
live tumor fragment, what we do is our first step.
We use our proprietary cutting instrument to
prepare. Therefore, prepare is to cut slices
of these biopsies. And then, which I think this step
is very important, we encapsulate it also with a
gel that we have developed. Why we encapsulate?
Remember, we are measuring immune checkpoint inhibitors and other io
therapies. So we need to make sure that the immune cells that they are
infiltrating that tumor microenvironment is there.
Also, we would like to preserve the tumor architecture.
And then what we do is we culture either with control
IgG or immune checkpoint inhibitor to
then assess 46 cytokines
by Luminex.
After doing all the assessment in the platform,
we have the ability to preserve the tissue
in an FFPE to do multiplex immunofluorescence
or spatial biology, as I will show you through the talk.
Elephas currently have four clinical trials that we have
enrolled over 400 patient. These clinical trials are for patient
with advanced metastatic settings,
and they have done in the major institutions
as well as community settings.
Samples from those patient enrolled in the clinical trials
have been run through the platform.
Most of these samples are either core needle biopsy or
forceps.
After we run through the platform and we obtain
the 46 cytokines, we are creating
this heat map we call training heat map.
And you can see a cytokine non-responder
cluster, where after ex vivo
treatments of functionally measuring the immune response,
you either have no movement of that cytokine, so what
happen in the IgG stay in the immune checkpoint inhibitor.
Some of the cytokines are downregulated.
When we compare with this macro cluster we call cytokine
respond, there's cluster, and you see a
coordinated upregulation of immune
inflammatory cytokines. And I will tell you later which those are.
So data science have created a classifier
using
the training heat map. This classifier
predict if a patient will be
responder or non-responder. What we have observed
after applying this classifier in a cohort of 28 patient,
93% of concordance of what
we have done ex vivo and what the patient had
received in the clinic and the observed clinical responses.
We can say that there is 100%
correlation of the predicted ex vivo
response and the clinical response when we
bucket
complete responses, partial responses, and stable disease as
disease control, and that is important.
Also, the same is true that when the patient did
not have any response or progressive disease in the clinic,
we have ex vivo predicted after immune checkpoint inhibitor
treatment that that patient will not respond, and that is the
eLive index, which is our prediction
algorithm that is based in the nine most
upregulated
cytokines.Now let's go
back to the training heat map
and let's focus on this cytokine responder cluster.
What are we seeing there?
So unsupervised hierarchical clustering
is identifying four different subclusters,
subclusters of response. So all of these specimens
are responding to immune checkpoint inhibitor data ex vivo.
Not all of them are responding through the same pathways.
So we have subcluster one that has the typical
cytokine of the TH1, and we call T cell
inflamed with a regulatory counterbalance.
And then all the way to subcluster four, and you can see that here you have
some cytokines are regulated, but over here you have much more.
So subcluster four is a polyfunctional activated with myeloid
angiogenic remodeling, and it's how we define
them. We're going to go one by one and study them
in terms of the proteomics and genomics.
Subcluster one, cytokines that you see in the
typical TH1 tumor microenvironment,
interferon gamma, CXCL9, CXCL10.
And many of the talks, they were very explicit
on what is happening in the tumor microenvironment.
You do have inflammation, you do have interferon gamma release, and
reactivation of the T cells. And of course,
counterbalance with CCL22 and
interleukin 10.
When we take a cervical cancer specimen representative of
the subcluster one,
we see after immune checkpoint inhibitor treatment,
68% of CD8 cytotoxic T cell
expressing CD69 that is an activation marker.
And that is the expected immune phenotype
after treating a tumor microenvironment that is responding to an immune checkpoint
inhibitor.
Also, non-small cell lung cancer in this spatial
biology analysis, we have seen immune
triads. We didn't know if we could see it in ex vivo
after immune checkpoint inhibitor, and they are here.
So immune triad are a cluster of CD8, CD4
T cells,
and dendritic cells.
And there is some literature over the past two years
correlating with the presence of this immune triads in patient
responding to immune checkpoint inhibitors.
Subcluster two is an interesting subcluster.
It has mixed regulatory, T-regs and
myeloid. Now we don't only have T-regs, myeloid are present.
Yes, we do have interferon gamma, and interferon gamma is the core
cytokine. So all the four subclusters have interferon gamma
in combination with other chemokines and cytokines.
So this one has CCL 19, 17, and 22,
that they are chemokines, that they are recruiting T cells as well
as T-regs. And then immune
activation of myeloid cells through the GCSF.
Subcluster three is the first time that we are seeing
cytotoxicity being present in one of the subclusters.
So again, interferon gamma, but this time granzyme A, granzyme B.
We do have the chemokines bringing the counterbalance,
and we start seeing VEGF.
This TNBC, a representative sample of the subcluster three.
We have, again, CD8 T cells
activated through CD69 and 137,
and in the non-small cell lung cancer, also some of the immune
triads.
Subcluster four is the most robust out of
all subclusters
with a very complex tumor microenvironment.
This one, we call it polyfunctional activated with myeloid
angiogenic remodeling,
and we have TH1, we also have T-regs, we
also have macrophages, myeloid signaling,
as well as VEGF. This liver cancer
specimen has CD3 T cells, macrophages, B
cells.
Interesting, in this particular non-small cell lung cancer
specimen that we took as an example from the subcluster
four does not have triads.
One of the hypothesis now at Elephas is
not only doing immune checkpoint inhibitors and monotherapy,
also combining with VEGF inhibitors and other type
of
small molecules.
Let's go now to the data that where we have
clinical follow-up
from the 28 patients that I show you. I'm going to show you two vignettes.
This patient has a TNBC that at three months they
have complete response.
The ELISE index, that again, it goes from zero all the way to
100,
30 being the cutoff to differentiate non-responder and
responder. This patient has an ELISE index of
100.
They have an immune phenotype that is
resembling of the subcluster three.
And when we look at the multiplex immunofluorescence, we have CD3,
we have myeloid as expected in the subcluster three.
This is my last vignette. This is a non-small cell lung cancer patient with
partial response that clearly mapped to a
subcluster one.
These are replicates. So for some of the patients that we have started with core
needle biopsy, we might have enough material to do
replicates, and that's what we do.
And the platform is super solid and robust that we have
concordance with all the
replicatesFor the multiplex immunofluorescence
in this one, it is interesting and we like to show it because we
have not only CD3 T cells, but also B
cells that colocalize,
and pathologies have
reported a potential TLS. And of course, T cell activation.
Again, these are tumor microenvironment that they've been treated with immune
checkpoint inhibitors, so it is expected that we have T cell
activation.
So conclusion, the Eli platform uses the ex
vivo cytokines profiling to predict
ex vivo responses with clinical responses, and I show you the
93% clinical concordance.
That unsupervised clustering of the cytokine
profiling data rendered two macroclusters
of responder that we have upregulation of
immune cytokines versus non-responders.
This subcluster analysis give us four
distinct unexpected immune phenotype of
responses after immune checkpoint inhibitor.
Cytokines define immune phenotype of response are
supported by cellular data, proteomics, and
genomics.
So the Eli platform provides an approach to elucidate not
only the biology of any immune
therapy drug, but also the mechanism of action.
We can see what are the cytokines that are regulated,
and we can study the mechanism of action.
I would like to thank the patient, clinician, and their clinical research staff, as
well as all the employees at Eliphus.
And a special thanks to Singular for generating all the
spatial data and Miromics for the analysis.
And if you are around tomorrow, 9:00 a.m., we are presenting this
poster that we are moving beyond this
biology to correlate with
single-cell data in patient treated with immune checkpoint inhibitors,
so how these four subclusters correlates.
Thank you, and happy to take any questions.
Could you come-
Do you want to come to the microphone?
Yeah.
Thank you very much for your interesting talk.
So, I was wondering, actually,
because you are taking a punch biopsies from a bulk tumor, so your ex
vivo response, would you think it precluded already the
tumor heterogeneity?
Yes, absolutely. And we are seeing that because we not only treat
with immune checkpoint inhibitors, so this is the whole core
needle biopsy is a punch biopsy.
What we do is we only do one well with biopsy for
each biopsy. If we have enough material, we can go to other wells, and we
sequentially treat, that is an Eliphus method that we have IP.
We sequentially treat with IgG and then with
immune checkpoint inhibitor, and we see that tumor heterogeneity
is there, and you can see it through the multiplex immunofluorescence.
And another question, thank you very much for this.
Because you're taking punch biopsies, what about the remaining tumors
that's in the patient's body? Because you're basically
getting the tumor heterogeneity from that punch biopsy and from different
fragments. But then how does the ex vivo profiling results
correlates to the remaining tumor that has shrunk or not responded?
Oh, that is a great question, and that is something that we get
asked quite often. We do take from the
main biopsy, the one that the pathologists are also taking.
What happen is the
radiologist take two biopsy, one of them go to pathology, and the other one
comes to Eliphus.
So far, we have not seen any discordance between
the prediction that we have done in the clinic and
other type of metastasis. So if we have seen ex vivo
treated responder, they do respond in the clinic.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
And I have a question, too. So you measure a lot of cytokines,
but what about just looking at interferon gamma?
You had four or five patients in your non-responder
category, but were those actually the ones that did well, that
were the 7% non-concordance?
I love that question. We also get asked that question, why you don't
measure interferon gamma or interferon gamma and CXCL10, because those are
the two cytokines that they are expressed in almost every
subcluster.
Data science at Julie, that is here in the audience, have done
a lot of analysis on trying to predict
the patient responder in the clinic with only interferon
gamma or interferon gamma and CXCL10 does not give
us this 93% correlation. You do need additional
cytokines, not only to define the immune phenotyping of the
patient, but also accurately predict if the patient is responding in the
clinic.
Good. Thank you.
So
in addition to the
treatment response, did you by chance look at how
those subclasser dictate the treatment resistant
and the patient survival?
Yeah. That's another wonderful question.
We are now, because we have 28 patient, we are mapping out
every single patient to all the subcluster and understanding
if those subclusters, they not only predict for responses, if not
predict for the duration of the response.
That is a great question, and that's what we are doing now while we are
collecting much more clinical data.
Great.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Thank you for coming. Yeah, I hope everyone learned
something from Diverse Model System of Cancer.
That conclude our mini symposia. Let's get
one more applause to all the speaker today.
Thanks.
Great.
Thank you.
So you're more than welcome also to a lunch we serve.
Yeah.